ou aboutissent vos déchets électroniques
quand vous achetez une télé un ordi un
téléphone vous payez des écoss frais
c'est comme ça dans toutes les provinces
plus l'appareil est gros plus les échos
frais sont élevés ces écoffrets
financent la collecte le transport et le
recyclage des produits électroniques en
fin de vie les fameux sert plus à rien
et qui gère le programme et donc en
poche les écoffrets les fabricants de
ces appareils eux-mêmes et oui est-ce
qu'il nous disent c'est que depuis 10
ans au Québec seulement tous les
serpents a rien ont rempli une file de
semi-remorque assez longue tenez vous
bien pour relier Montréal et Rimouski et
ils ont tous été envoyés à des
entreprises de réemploi et de recyclage
waouh mais au bout de la ligne quelle
proportion de cette matière est
réellement recyclée impossible de le
savoir cette information les fabricants
de la garde pour eux secret commercial
dommage parce que ce détail essentiel
nous permettrait de savoir programme est
efficace et si nos écoffrets sont bien
utilisés passez le mot